all right let's bring in mike pompeo fox
news contributor former secretary of
state good morning to you
good morning good morning to you all
we'll start with your reaction
on dr fauci and everything that's coming
out with him lately he had his first
interview with nicole wallace
yesterday and she really didn't uh grill
him about
those emails what's your reaction about
these 3 200 pages of emails that uh
buzzfeed got so i've seen some of the
emails
what really matters here is when when it
mattered most when the
chinese were covering this up in early
january of 2020
dr fauci certainly would have seen the
same intelligence that i saw
we would certainly have known that the
risk that this came from the laboratory
was real we would have known that the
chinese communist party didn't want any
of us to know that
and that raised red flags throughout the
entire united states government for
for far too long dr francis let those of
us who are out there talking about it
carry the mantle and we couldn't get
science we got politics instead and
that's what you saw in the left-wing
media
you saw politics trumping science and
that delayed our capacity to respond to
what the chinese communist party foisted
upon the world
directly affects our national security
here's an example of some of the emails
that i think are eye brown raising
this is an email to dr peter danzig this
is what he's responding after anthony
fauci
sidelined the talk of a lab leak quote
april 18
2020. i'm sure you remember this i just
want to say a personal thank you on
behalf of our staff and collaborators
for publicly standing up and stating
that the scientific evidence supports
a natural origin from coven 19 from a
bat to a human spillover
not a lab release from the wuhan
institute of virology
from my perspective your comments are
brave and coming from your trusted voice
will help dispel the myths being spun
around the viruses
origins now your job secretary of state
knowing that that was going on behind
the scenes
anthony fauci saying it happened by
happenstance wet market
as opposed to a wuhan lab where tom
cotton was one of the first to say
let's look at that lab
yeah so center kind of got it right
right after that email that you
described in early may i began to talk
about this as well
we we knew that the evidence was
accumulating was piling up showing that
the theory of the wet market
didn't hold water and that the much more
likely scenario was that this had come
from the
virology lab in wuhan and this guy daisy
the fellow that wrote this email
he's got dirty hands he was he was
involved in this laboratory there was
taxpayer money that was funneled through
an alliance that he was responsible for
you know too brian he was he was one of
the lead investigators that the
that was sent in to take a look at this
there's a lot of questions to be
answered i think dr
fauci has a lot of questions to answer
and this matters your point brian about
this being about american national
security that lab is still operating
that work is still going on there today
and we could have something like this
happen again and the
chinese communist party refused to tell
us what they know the united states
president biden must demand that we get
these answers and we need to know
how the u.s government uh how the u.s
government dr
fauci desek all the folks that were
involved in underwriting this laboratory
what they knew when they knew it because
this will help us answer the important
questions that will keep us all safe
okay that's the perfect segue to the
question i have for you mr secretary
you've always been a straight shooter
we know there were some behind the
scenes scuffles between the president
and fauci
and you guys did y'all know something
was going on behind the scenes that
there was this connection
back then what did you guys know at the
time
so i have to be a little careful you saw
lawrence what we were able to release on
january 15th director ratcliff the head
of the dni at the time and i
had been working for an awfully long
time to get as much information released
as we possibly could
we knew we could we could watch all the
facts begin to align that suggested
that the most likely case we knew about
the the doctors we watched them
disappeared journalists we knew that
people had taken ill
in wuhan we began to see this evidence
of cumulative we were trying to get it
out we were certainly trying to make
sure everybody in the united states what
government
so we could respond sorry to interrupt
what prevented you guys from pushing it
out all the
information it's complicated process
lauren said there's still more
information
that's sitting there that i think ought
to be out but you have sources and
methods intelligence things that need to
be protected i was a director of the cia
i understand that but we need to make
sure that the american people know
everything that we can
and then frankly we don't know the
answer for sure we need the chinese
communist party to be held accountable
will we ever know the answer
the origins of this virus that killed
millions of people around the world
yeah i think we will it may take
years and years and years we know it has
already taken too long
the chinese communist party could answer
this in 30 seconds if they chose to do
so
but i think one day we'll know some
brave chinese doctors some
technician will break free and they'll
share the information we'll we'll be
able to validate what happened i
we need to get the answer to this
question right i will say this just uh
in terms of what emails subscribe to
what you're saying
uh this exchange between the scientists
richard henderson to fouchy
he said unusual features on the virus
make up a really small part of the
genome
so one has to look at every very hard at
all the sequences to see
that some of the features potentially
look engineered
isn't that nice so that might have been
manufactured and made
brian you know all these emails that
you're seeing now
are entirely consistent as well with
what the propaganda machine inside of
china was pressing and what the world
health organization was pressing as well
we can't forget that all this time not
only not only was there an absence of
information from the chinese communist
party but
they were trying to tell us that this
came from america they were they were
actually engaged in propaganda
suggesting this was natural
they are they are hard at it we we we've
got to help chinese communist party
council i haven't seen any evidence that
this administration is prepared to do
that the american people should demand
that they be held accountable there are
there are lots of tools that we can use
to do that
mr secretary i want to pivot to another
issue kamala harris has gone 71 days
without a press
uh press conference since being tapped
to run the border
crisis now she'll visit guatemala on
sunday in mexico
on monday we know that you brief the
the biden administration during the
transition about how their policy
could impact the border the remaining
mexico policy what should she
be saying to these countries when she
goes to meet with them
uh this upcoming week
unfortunately she's not going to say
what needs to be said what what is
easy to do it's just to go back to the
policies that we had in place lawrence
that
they worked it took us a little while to
get them in place but we'd we
turned off the magnet we had we had
prevented this
massive humanitarian crisis and this
enormous national security crisis from
taking place you should tell them
we're going to go back to the policies
that we had back in december of last
year
this will keep those countries want to
keep their people too they'd like to
have their talents stay
inside of their country we we need to
tell them that this is what they're
going to have to do they're going to
have to enforce their own borders and
we're going to enforce ours
so let's talk about the russia meeting
that's coming up between
joe biden and vladimir putin we keep
seeing all these ransomware attacks and
they're being linked
to russia a reporter was asking jinsaki
about it in the press room uh
yesterday and they say that they're not
being tested by putin listen to this and
we'll get your reaction
mr president will you retaliate against
russia for this latest ransomware attack
do you think putin is testing you
he says putin's not testing him what do
you say
you know here's what i can say for sure
these kinds of things
uh in our administration were different
and kind and the responses
to russian activity was different in
kind we we didn't give them money we
didn't let them build out their energy
pipeline
we provided weapon systems to the
ukrainians to defend themselves we built
out our military
all of these things vladimir putin
didn't like and now you see you see
these ransomware attacks i haven't seen
the intelligence but they
they look they have all the hallmarks of
having come from russia when president
biden meets with president putin next
week he needs to make clear that there
will be real costs
not just on these thugs these criminals
who are engaged in this conduct
but from the people who are supporting
and enabling to cut if it in fact is
coming from inside of russia
vladimir putin has an awful lot of
capacity to control what happens inside
of his country
and the leaders of that country need to
be held accountable if we continue to
have these things which can wreak
enormous devastation on our economy
they said it they had their under
secretary come out and say we're going
to make things very
unpleasant for the president leading up
to june 16th
and now they've taken out the mta
through ransomware jbs the colonial
pipeline
and the massachusetts steamboat
authority let alone which just happened
with this
meat hit in the middle of the country so
this is a
they would keep getting shots to the
forehead and we don't answer with
anything
yeah brian these are the ones that we
know about that have been made public
goodness knows
how many have taken place inside some
private company who just decided to
to pay the bribe to pray the branson to
ransom to make it go away
we're going to have to impose real costs
we're going to have to defend ourselves
and brian we have lots of tools some of
which we can't say much about
but know this we have lots of tools
where we can impose real costs on the
russians and those
cyber hackers we have to do this we this
is a sovereignty issue
this is not terribly different from
someone who attacks the united states in
the ways that we've known
as a matter of history and we need to
treat it as just that kind of attack
mr secretary we want to pivot to this
story right here netanyahu rivals agreed
to form a new government to oust him
what does this mean for the u.s israel
relations this is our law
uh uh israel's longest-serving prime
minister this is our most trusted ally
will that relationship and that bond
remain with this new
government lawrence i was in
israel this past weekend for four days
while this was all taking place
this government is a confusing one that
they are trying to form it's not
completely over yet it's not certain
that they will be successful in doing so
you've got arab parties you've got hard
right party you've got the
what would be traditionally the israeli
center left party this is going to be
really difficult for them to make good
decisions and and that's not good
it's not good for the us israel
relationship i hope that whatever
government gets formed
continues to build on this important
security relationship we were such great
partners
with the israelis we've seen what's been
happening in iran
and the fact that we were able to
isolate them as part of the abraham
accords
i hope that whatever government
ultimately takes place whatever
government forms that's the israelis
business
that they'll continue to build out on
what we did which really created more
peace more prosperity and indeed more
stability in the middle east
yeah well benjamin netanyahu was and
president obama famously
uh disliked each other in fact president
obama worked behind the scenes that he
wouldn't get re-elected which is
unbelievable
and then joe biden with no word yet on
how this is going to
affect relations but when you have to
make a deal within within arab sector
of the israeli government this is
unprecedented
so what do they give up what do they
promise
it'll be interesting to see brian what
all deals had to be cut to make this
happen
right this if they don't get it done
they'll be a fifth election it's kind of
messy stuff inside of israel
but brian we can see what happens when
the united states isn't strong
the iranians will underwrite hezbollah
we saw what they did when they
underwrote hamas firing rockets into
tel aviv and to jerusalem american
leadership our partnership with israel
matters an awful lot and i hope
whichever government ultimately gets
formed in israel
builds on that thank you so much for
being on with us
thanks secretary thank you all have a
good morning you got crazy time in the
world hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now